local family closer to finding justice
earlier this month their bulldog named
bamboo was found dead after he was
stolen tonight the family says a suspect
has been arrested in that case victoria
saha first brought you this story she's
here live in studio now joining us with
an update brian denise like you said
we've been following this story every
day since we first aired it and many of
you at home also expressed your anger
about this situation but today is a day
bamboo's family has been waiting for
wanting those responsible and taking
bamboo away from the only home he knew
to pay the consequences
these past two weeks have been so bitter
and so angry the homes feel very empty
without bamboo bamboo's parents mohan
gomutai and angelica shming are still
finding it hard to come to terms of
their loss whatever pain we feel right
now whatever anguish and anger
it's probably nowhere near to what he
went through their ten-year-old bulldog
bamboo was in his yard the evening of
june 6 when he disappeared hours of
searching for him led to surveillance
video that showed men from a flooring
company working next door taking bamboo
putting him in their truck and driving
away
confrontations led to denial from the
workers i told them you can work here
tomorrow i'll say good morning to you
give my dog back the next day bamboo's
lifeless body was found in north las
vegas nowhere near where bamboo lived in
the southwest area of the valley las
vegas metro police's animal cruelty
division got involved and by wednesday
bamboo's parents say an arrest was made
for a suspect from the flooring company
8 news now is choosing to not name the
suspect until we receive confirmation
from police but court records show there
are charges for larceny and animal
cruelty i didn't think i was going to
feel okay if i heard he got arrested
because that's not enough you know and
then when i did hear he got arrested
there was a sense of relief the flooring
company has continued to deny any
involvement
the suspect was supposed to be in court
tomorrow but records show he posted bond
he is set to appear in court again in
july as for bamboo a necropsy was
completed and his parents are still
waiting to get the results back